en el Valle de Mexicali Baja California
predomina un paisaje árido
antes era un lugar lleno de agua y de
vida con la llegada del delta del Río
Colorado
Alfonso tambo es el gobernador de los
Cucapá una etnia que se asentó aquí hace
500 años recuerda su viejo caudal río me
trae recuerdos de nuestros antepasados y
pues mis padres también me iban a pescar
y todos al río Colorado
es una ecologista que ha sido testigo
del daño en la zona provocado por el
cambio climático la sobreexplotación
para uso agrícola y la contaminación
aparte que vemos aquí en esta zona era
por donde pasaba el río Colorado
actualmente tenemos una zona muy
degradada del Río en donde vemos
principalmente pinos Salado y no vemos
agua superficial
al otro lado de la frontera en Estados
Unidos el río nace en Colorado y su
caudal de 2.200 kilómetros beneficia a
más de 40 millones de personas de los
dos países
desde el aire la piloto Stephanie Wells
anotado los considerables cambios en la
corriente del caudal del río
me siento culpable porque durante muchas
décadas Estados Unidos ha tomado todo el
agua del río Colorado antes de que llega
a México
para revertir el daño desde Estados
Unidos y México brotan las iniciativas
una puesta binacional son los flujos
pulso que se liberan de las presas entre
mayo y septiembre gracias a estos del
río partido en dos vuelve a conectarse
Alejandro rosas es hidrólogo de sonoran
instituto y explica los beneficios de
este entrelazamiento al llegar la marea
y interceptar el río
genera también unas condiciones de agua
salobres que también benefician a
especies que requieren de estas
condiciones para subsistir a la parte
esta iniciativa voluntarios y
organizaciones se han dado a la tarea de
reforestar la zona
una lucha que ha pasado desde el campo
hasta el arte
Karina es poeta hace un llamado a la
conservación a su manera y pues a mí me
surgen un poco las letras y creo que es
la oportunidad de poder este plasmar lo
mis sentimientos hacia esa tristeza que
tenemos los esfuerzos binacionales no
revertirán de un día para el otro el
grave daño que toca el río
pero han logrado despertar conciencia
entre los habitantes de ambos lados de
la